hey
retrospective time and guess what i'm
very excited because i'm finally getting
around to doing another
dario argento movie i think we've done
what suspiria and we did
a deep red yeah so i decided because
shutter had it for a long time and i was
like
finally get around to doing this one i'm
finally getting around to doing inferno
this is the sort of i don't want to call
it a sequel to suspiria because it's
i guess thematically it's sort of a
sequel
um this is uh as most horror fans
probably know
the second in dario argento's so-called
three mothers trilogy
uh which is kind of based on a thomas de
quincey uh
prose poem called levana and our ladies
of sorrow from his
suspiria du profundus which kind of
talked about
three he didn't really call them witches
like in the text but he was just talking
about how there were these
three women like mythological women and
it's kind of like you had your
three fates you had your three furies
you had three graces
you also had three sorrows and these
women were like responsible for all of
the
terrible things that happened in the
world so
uh dario argento and daria nickelode who
was his girlfriend
wife at the time and also co-wrote
suspiria and also co-wrote this one
although she didn't get any credit for
it
um so they came up with this story where
they want to do like a fairy tale witch
kind of thing and they it's kind of this
loose thing
now like i said it took forever for the
third one to come out which was mother
of tears that came out in 2007.
um there was probably a reason why it
took so long for it to come out
i admit that i've only seen mother of
tears once
uh probably about 2008 i think about a
year after it came out like i got it on
dvd
and i remember not really liking it uh
because it's
it didn't seem anything like the first
two
which at least have some kind of
thematic similarity um
but you know i'm willing to give another
shot because you know ozzy argento's in
it and i'll offer and stuff like that
but so inferno came out three years
after the spirit came out in
1980 and dario argento has said that
he really did not have a fun time making
this movie because for a large part of
the production he was suffering from a
really bad case of hepatitis
and uh so he couldn't really so some of
the some of the time he had to like come
to the set like in the bed or like in a
chair like they had to roll him out of
the thing
and uh so he said pretty much his
memories of making it are tainted by
that
um it's supposed to be set like half in
rome and half in new york they shot most
of it in rome but they did actually
shoot a week in new york
um you know some shots in central park
and everything like that so it's not
completely set in room
also uh for you trivia like italian
horror movie trivia fans
this was the last movie that mario bava
worked on
although i think he just did like
special effects and type of stuff like
he did like some of the matte paintings
and like some of the trick shots and
stuff like that in the background
so while i will say that
this movie i love this movie
but it suffers in comparison with
suspiria which a lot of movies
do because suspiria is amazing
this one kind of tries to do the same
thing
you know like in a thematic sort of way
it looks kind of the same with those
beautiful like saturated colors and
those really gorgeous like shots and
angles and stuff like that
um it's not quite as over the top and
the score which is by keith emerson
is good but it's not as awesome as the
goblin one from
suspiria was um which [ __ ] the goblin
score from suspiria i just like i i can
listen to that whole [ __ ] album just
on its own
merits it's like a [ __ ] really good
album the keith emerson one is good but
it's a little more piano based it's not
as
over the top not as operatic or
bombastic except for like the last song
which is like that
kind of operatic like i like that one
that's like that kicks ass
but even though i think it's a little
incongruous where they put it in the
movie i wish they'd kind of saved it
till the end
but you know what are you gonna do so
this one kind of has a similar thing
where
you got this woman and she lives in this
old building in new york she's a poet
and she buys this book from this creepy
old like
crippled uh bookseller named kazanian
and it's a book about the three mothers
and she becomes like obsessed with this
mythology and she thinks maybe that
the three mothers are real and that her
building
is one of the buildings that was built
for these witches which because that's
part of the mythology that there was an
alchemist named vareli
and he built these three like houses of
evil like for these witches to live like
as their bases of operation
um and that kind of retcons it a little
bit and says you know the one
uh modern suspiriora suspiriorum was at
the one in fryeburg
germany which is what happened in
suspiria the mother of tears is about
modern modern lacrimarum and that one is
set in
i think that's in viterbo actually or
rome or whatever so this is this one is
new york based even though most of it
takes place in italy
honestly so she gets obsessed with it
and starts like looking around
for to find out if this building is
actually
the the seat of like where this woman
lives
and she writes to her brother mark who
is a music student in rome
and you know tells him about she's like
i think is this the building and it's
like i think i'm in trouble and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
but he doesn't get to read the whole
letter like his girlfriend like he
leaves it somewhere and his girlfriend
like picks it up
and like people start getting murdered
by
you know your standard giallo black
gloved killer
and so he's not entirely sure like
what's going on with his sister so he
like rushes to new york because he's
worried about her like he tries to call
her and the [ __ ] lion's all [ __ ] up
and he can't get a straight answer out
of her so he gets there and she's
disappeared
and then all of this other weird [ __ ]
starts to happen now
i will say that much like suspiria
this the plot it has a plot but just
like a lot of dario argento's movies
it's like he forgets what the plot is
it's not well it's not
important yeah he's more concerned about
the look of it he's more concerned about
making this
his movies are like very nightmarish
very
fairytale-esque so i mean
if he's gonna go for you know like in
suspiria like this woman is like
exploring this
you know dance academy she opens a door
and falls in a room and it's full of
barbed wire
just because i mean you wouldn't really
have that in real life probably
but it looked cool in the movie it was
just like a cool weird thing that might
happen in a dream
so he's like well i'm putting in the
[ __ ] movie so
the same thing happens in inferno one of
the best um you know examples of this
is like very near the beginning of the
movie where
um you know this the woman that uh
starts the whole thing off
and she has this clue about where like
some of the keys are where you know
uh how you find out that this if this
house is one of the uh houses of evil or
whatever
and she goes down into the cellar to
like check it out and see if she can
find like the
the name and the image of the witch and
everything
and she goes down there and she drops
her keys into what she thinks is a
puddle
in the cellar and then she sticks her
hand down to the puddle and it's just
like really really deep
and then she can't get the keys and then
they slip off this thing that they're
caught on
and she goes down to this thing and it's
a whole [ __ ] ballroom
like underneath this [ __ ] building
it's just
all full of water that was weird because
there's carpeting in there there's
chandeliers in yeah there's like you
know
tables and chairs i was tripping
and then there's like a rotten corpse
down there
[Laughter]
one of the things you watch these movies
in it and it kind of makes sense that
during the 60s and 70s the japanese were
more influenced by what was going on in
italy
when it came to you know when it came to
do with filmography yeah they're more
influenced by that than they were
america i think a lot of american
studios didn't really want to work with
japanese studios
but the italians and japanese works
together
but a lot of japanese cinema i think was
was uh influenced by dario agentos with
the lighting and filmography
seems like it yeah it really does this
is well the odd thing about
okay so 20th century fox had actually
distributed
suspiria in the united states even
though
they they distributed it under like um
like a subsidiary
i don't know if they were like ashamed
of it or something like international
classics or something in that area so in
that era foreign films were just a no-no
especially italian films
but it should be said that they put it
out and it was a huge success
they were like surprised yeah um because
it was just i mean suspiria like i said
it's a [ __ ] classic it was just this
weird like ultra violent like especially
compared to other you know american
films at the time
i remember when i was a kid my dad going
through television and as soon as he
realized that something was italian he's
like oh no he'd turn it
well nicely with like a spaghetti
western type stuff now some of the [ __ ]
he liked
yeah but i guess i think it was just
because quality
from italy was spotty it was either
really bad or it was really good
but yeah i think was a problem the
american audience did not like anything
that looked like it was dubbed
and most italian movies they did dub
them because usually um
you know not always but i think in the
vast majority of cases
most of the actors it was like an
international cast they had americans
brits
germans they had all this other stuff so
they basically just said well everyone
just speak your native language and then
we'll just dub it all into english or
we'll dub it all into italian
later on for the theater market and
that's generally what they did
so even now like daria argento's movies
and everything
like that a lot of times you're not
hearing the person's real voice
even if they are speaking english
because they just dubbed everything over
with the same language and there's no
original dub every country got their own
dub
they did so you know because because no
one in those movies spoke the same
language
yeah there wasn't really yeah so there
wasn't really a real dub or an official
dub
they just tried to they tried to
maximize what they had
yeah that was just how they did it and
like i said since they were usually
working with an international cast
and they figured well it's better to
just have like americans or brits
dub everybody into english rather than
having people
because even like the italians and
germans and stuff that could speak
english
they said oh well maybe their accent is
too thick i mean because even in
suspiria like udokir was in that
and he's a german uh he could speak
english
but he does have kind of i don't think
his accent's all that thick but
you know they did they dubbed him over
with like an american actor
in suspiria which i always thought was
very i just remember the set i was old
enough to remember the 70s attitude
if a [ __ ] foreign accent came out of
somebody the
older people that time just they just
didn't want uh i mean they
they they dubbed mad max and road
warrior
that shows you how intelligent they're
[ __ ]
how intelligent the studios yeah
it tells you how intelligent the
american movie studios were at that day
they were [ __ ] dumb
they didn't just go this is an awesome
movie listen to it in its original
language or listen to it
with the australian accent it's
happening in australia this is what they
sound
like this adds something to the move
they just didn't think that way
they're always trying to pass everything
off as an american movie i'm just so
glad they don't really do that anymore
it's like most foreign movies that you
can like if you like once they have a
netflix or whatever you can watch a
dubbed version
but i kind of feel like most people
nowadays would just rather watch it in
the original language and read because i
don't want it
it's too distracting that that's not the
people's real voices
when me and my me and my buddies were
[ __ ] watching mad max 1 and i think
even mad max
2 but i remember mad max 1 we we're like
why is this [ __ ] [ __ ] dubbed
you know what i mean it sounded cheap
real cheap
later on we got our hands on the [ __ ]
original australian dub and all of a
sudden that movie was just [ __ ]
awesome as a masterpiece
it makes a big difference yeah because
i've watched a few movies
like and i didn't realize they were
dubbed like for example on netflix i
watched um
under the shadow which is an iranian
movie uh horror movie
and i didn't realize that there was a
subtitled version so i watched the
dubbed version and i was like oh man i
was like this seems like such an awesome
movie but the dubbing is like just
really really bothering me but then like
later on
i discovered oh there was you know a
subtitle so i watched that and i was
like okay that's much better
a lot better because it's like it just
it really makes a huge difference it's
like we were watching one thing i think
in
what was a japanese movie or watching
that chinese movie that chinese science
fiction movie yeah that's right where
they were trying to save the earth
it was all freezing and yeah because the
dubbed version came on and i was like
i'm like this is driving me crazy turned
over to chinese and
all these things that's better yeah well
it made sense i just i can't stand
but like i said in the dario argento
movies it never really bothered me just
because
i know that that's kind of how they
planned to do it so it's not like it was
just like an afterthought
um so i just kind of like roll with it
but
what i was gonna say was that you know a
long time ago
was that suspiria was such a big susp
surprise hit
that 20th century fox you know so dark
so dario argento and daria nickelode
came out and said okay well since that
was
such a big success we'll do a follow-up
we'll do inferno
um you know they wrote daria nickelode
like wrote the story and then daario
took her
notes and wrote a screenplay out of it
and like i said didn't give her any
credit although
i think she said later on that she
didn't ask for any so
i don't think it was him being an
[ __ ] or anything because he always
seemed like an okay dude these movies
you know even the british kind of copied
them in a way that that psychomania
wasn't it called psychomania yeah that
movie had a lot of dario types
although that came out before well
dario had done he had done a couple of
giallo movies before because
uh [ __ ] when did psychomedia came out
what 73 because they had some of that
giallo lighting man
he did um he had done a couple of
geology moves i think he had
on gray velvet and um maybe bird with
the crystal plumage was 71 i want to say
or 72. so he had done like a couple
but suspiria didn't come out until 1977.
and that's when he really
turned it up well the thing about it is
that if you want to see where
daario got it you can go back to
mario bava blood and black lace
which is not quite as extreme but you
can see
like where that where his where that
came from like he's not copying him
exactly
but he just he kind of took that
that kind of nascent thing and you think
baba's work would might have inspired
psychomania because i was watching the
cycle
it had that italian vibe especially when
when the guy goes to his mom's house
yeah and just the way it was you know
decorated anyway it was lit in the
inside it just
seemed like a giant movie to me yeah
well well jello had been
i think the first giallo movie which was
mario baba
was uh the girl who knew too much even
though that was black and white
um but there were a lot of gela movies
that came out in the 60s
so it's it's not always that lighting
but it's always that real baroque
um you know interiors and like that like
all those crazy like operatic angles and
all that kind of stuff
it's just really stylized some more so
than others
but um i mean daario is primarily known
as like a visual stylist like he was
very into this the fairy tale dreamlike
sort of vibe he made giallo giallo films
too like early in his career and
but he just has like a really
interesting like
eye like the way he comes up with this
kind of [ __ ] so he took all those tropes
and just like
now what about the moment polanski's
hooking the tenant would you call that
kind of like a jalla movie no
that's that's not a jail okay not not at
all because when i was a kid i could
watch him back to back
on you know what i mean on cable yeah
and that and i really didn't
differentiate them
in fact i would not see this there's a
bone of contention and i think i talked
about this a little bit on my suspiria
review
i would not call suspiria or inferno
giallo movies either even though they
have
that look to them and they have a couple
of things a giallo movie
is generally a crime movie it's a
it's a gloved and masked killer who goes
around
picking off it's like a slasher movie so
like yeah sort of
yeah that kind yeah that kind of has
that vibe too and it's like and it has
like a bunch of red hair in here it's
more like a mystery
all right but with gory operatic
elements
suspiria and inferno have elements of
that
like you know inferno has like a black
black gloved killer he's going around
you don't find out who it is they're not
technically
cause it's not a murderer but it's not
really a murder mystery okay
um you know what i mean it's it's two
different you could argue like if you
want to say suspiria is a giant that's
fine it's like i'm not gonna fight you
or anything but it's like
personally i think suspiria is more of a
supernatural
thriller it says witches and [ __ ] like
that giallo don't usually have
supernatural elements i have seen a
couple that do but it's very very rare
it has badass lighting though man i
like how it was shot ever everything in
suspiria and inferno in particular
my old house that i used to live in in
daytona i decided i was going to
decorate the whole thing like i was the
paint
scheme and like all that kind of stuff i
was going to do it like suspirian
inferno
i even did like an inferno if you guys
remember there are these great like
these black
doors with these red like insets that
are like kind of art nouveau looking
and i painted like all my doors to look
like that
like i couldn't afford to do the whole
inset thing like in the red like in the
movie but i just like painted them to
make it look like that like
you know trump lloyd type of thing and
they looked really fantastic
but yeah so these are beautiful
beautiful looking movies you just have
to approach them
in a way that you're not they're not
logical necessarily and
in fact dario argento himself has said
that a lot of movies
a lot of his movies are very young in he
use like he uses like a lot of jungian
uh kind of consciousness type of stuff
where
particularly in inferno which is kind of
more like even though
it's called inferno and the thing ends
with like a big fire
and everything but most of the symbolism
in it
is water symbolism like you know she
goes down in the ballroom in the
beginning there's like always like
dripping water there's always just
you know and at one point the character
mark
he's played by uh lee mccloskey who's in
a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
soap operas and all that other kind of
stuff back in the day he was actually
quite famous
um you know he has like passes out in
dreams about like ocean waves and all
this kind of stuff
so there's all this like water like
womb-like kind of
uh you know because i guess because of
the three mothers the whole
mother womb type life-giving type stuff
i i kind of feel like he's getting into
that and also
the whole thing about going underneath
the buildings and there being like water
underneath the buildings and
secret tunnels and mazes like underneath
the building so it's like it's not
logical at all
i have dreams like that though but yeah
but it's it's just this really dream
like
kind of um imagery so you really kind of
have to take his movies
and and i know that a lot of people
don't they're not for everybody
they're not for everybody like there's
like a particular type of people that
like them i just
love like the whole these movies and
like all giallo movies like i just
really love the whole aesthetic of it
the whole
i could watch them like all day long to
me they look good they're shot well
there's some good imagery in them
there's some good scenes in them
but for me they're a little slow they're
slow and plotting
um but that's just me i mean
yeah that that's something i don't like
about them yeah you know i mean
if they they they'll kind of do they'll
kind of take 15 minutes to do something
that i think should take more like five
minutes to do but
they're it's it's like i said they're
trying to give you an experience that
the audience
would enjoy it's more an immersive kind
of experience and like i said
you know what i was going to say before
was that because suspiria was such a big
hit
20th century fox um you know gave
uh dario dario argento the money to do
inferno because he said okay well we can
do a follow-up to it since that was like
such a big surprise hit
so he gave him three million dollars
they got a couple like some more money
like
first from some other investors they
made the movie
the movie came out in italy and was like
a really big success i mean there was
like lines around the block it's like
they had to turn people away and [ __ ]
like that because it was [ __ ] dario
argento right
and then 20th century fox for whatever
reason didn't even release it
in the united states after all of that
like they gave him money to do it
suspiria was a giant hit
and it's like he says he thinks what
happened was that
before the movie came out like it came
out in italy and it was a success there
but at 20th century fox i guess the
management changed out
and he's like it wasn't just my movie it
was just like pretty much all the movies
that had been greenlit like under the
previous management
they just said [ __ ] those movies because
they didn't want to deal with them i
guess because someone else had done them
so he's like so they didn't even release
it it sat on
the shelf for five years then they put
it out in the u.s
for like a week or something like in new
york city
and then they just later released it to
like vhs it's like they didn't put it
out in the [ __ ] theater
which is stupid it wasn't their work
and they probably didn't want to compete
against something else that they had
going they didn't want it you know yeah
he said they jumped to like a bunch of
movies that had been
like under that you know that came out
around the same time
at the same time they probably just had
other ideas to make money you know
that's all it was
yeah it's yeah i don't think it was
anything personal against him or against
the movie or anything
um you know what i mean so i think maybe
that experience
kind of soured him on you know working
within the big hollywood system because
like i said it took him you know however
long until 2007 to make mother of tears
and i just like i said i remember that
one not being very good just because it
didn't seem
thematically similar his movies kind of
went downhill for me after
i think the last one of his that i liked
was
uh stendall syndrome um which actually i
just rewatched
probably a month or two ago and i still
really liked it like it's still really
held up
but i think all the ones i saw after
that like the card player like that
horrible dracula one
um we're just bad and it's just i
remember
i don't remember mother of tears being
bad i just remember being really
disappointed in it because it didn't
look like
because you know i wish that he had made
the trilogy
at the time you know what i mean because
you got suspiria this like amazing
um and you know another thing too is
that suspiria was such an amazing
[ __ ] classic
movie just this gorgeous looking you
know opera
of violence and everything and anything
that came after that was not gonna be as
good
and i don't think inferno is as good um
but at least it had some kind of
thematic continuation
with suspiria it sort of looked the same
it sort of had a similar theme to it
you you know what i mean so i wish that
you know a couple years after inferno
had come out
he had made you know the third movie
this
the weird thing and this always like
weirded me out so
you know suspiria comes out inferno
comes out
which um you know was about uh
you know about tenebrum and then
the heat then he made the movie tenebre
which you would think would also be one
of the three mothers movies but it
wasn't it was just a giallo
so i was like why i wonder why he called
it that and then he called that one
inferno i don't know it was like it
really bothered me it's like you
couldn't just like switch the titles
i don't know that just bugged me but i
just wish that it would have been so it
would have been like this
you know three thing that went together
so
you know the the sad thing was inferno
didn't really do
as well as it could have just because it
kind of got [ __ ] on
by 20th century fox which put all you
know the management put all this money
into it and then they just
you know change management out and they
didn't want to release they didn't
[ __ ] release the thing well it kind
of makes sense from the american point
of view because if you look at what
america what
what mainstream hollywood does is it
just makes very
generic [ __ ] especially during that era
it's just generic stuff
most of those movies are forgotten think
about what they made during the
decades of the 60s and 70s a lot of it's
kind of forgotten
although a lot of [ __ ] great movies
yeah but you know it's kind of a rarity
we know that for for every one that is a
hit that you remember there's like 50 of
them that are long forgotten
although i think that's true of any era
really and i don't know i saw an
analysis and said that the heyday
actually was the 80s in certain parts of
the 90s
and it was because the system works
different back then directors were
actually
were able to tell the story and to
direct producers kind of
when we're standing in the background
that we're not trying to
uh have creative input and or make the
make the movie happen
uh then what's happened recently is that
producers
want to have all this creative input and
they're making people take
take scenes in and out of the movies
that the directors put in there and
[ __ ] the movie all up
then the movie fails and then the
producer is like why did i lose my money
you lost your [ __ ] money because you
didn't listen to the damn director
that's
and that a lot of the great movies from
the 80s and the 90s were because the
director was able to do his job
well i think that was true the 60s and
70s and i mean 60s and 70s were probably
the age of the auteur
where directors were kind of a lot of
times were given a free hand really
i mean they got away with some crazy
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] 70s they
probably would not fly anymore but um
well even in the 80s there's dude did
[ __ ] that wouldn't fly anymore
yeah and it's nice but like i said i
think it's always been
a hassle i mean directors have always
complained about working within the
system because anytime there's a system
where there's all this money and there's
millions of dollars to be lost you're
gonna have other people like
in you know intruding on your vision
because a movie
is you know a large it's a group effort
it's not just one person making stuff
but i do like that the way nowadays it's
kind of going more toward
crowdfunding and you know and and making
your own [ __ ] and like
having places where people can see it um
you know so the hollywood way of doing
things is an old-fashioned way
and not good not good
i it's just it's a very bloated way of
making movies
you just have a producer that [ __ ]
has a [ __ ] ton of money
come forth and [ __ ] say i want to
make this movie right here this is the
director
and then [ __ ] you know i mean point
appoints the director
and then he stops the director from
doing what he's doing and puts his own
[ __ ] vision in there and the
director's like i don't know if that's
gonna work
the next thing you know you have these
[ __ ] abomination movies that fail
you know what i mean well it's stay the
[ __ ] out of the movie well like i said
it's always kind of the same and you
know me being
you know an artistic person uh you know
being a graphic designer and stuff i've
run into many many situations where
you know where people that
are you know kind of in charge or
whatever but aren't creative people
are like telling you you need to do this
the other thing and it either can't be
done or it's going to look stupid
and you can't really tell them that
because they just want what they want
and you just have to do it and
kind of that's just what you have to do
because even though you think it looks
like crap
and you don't think it's going to work
but they're the ones with the money so
it's like what are you gonna do it kind
of ends up like that
and yeah if you ask me a lot a lot of
money people just [ __ ] up everything
they touch anyway
they're not artistic yeah and you know
like i said that's
that's kind of been a problem since it's
time too yeah you've got
money if you got money chances are
you're not artistic let an artist do
some [ __ ]
yeah you're you're good at making money
you're not good at [ __ ] yeah that's
too completely different
sometimes it sometimes it measures very
rare but it's
not usually exactly and a person who
makes a lot of money usually is very
unlikely to be able to tell you what's
cool and what isn't the [ __ ]
don't know what's cool
well because usually you know making
more money means you appeal to more
people
and the more people you appeal to
usually like the more bland something is
yeah
not always but generally and then
they're riding
on waves they're not creating a wave
that's another thing
you know is that you know guys who make
a lot of money
also tend to be [ __ ] followers all
right uh
well yeah because they're like well
that's that's a proven way
we're gonna go that way so they don't
make anything new
yeah they just [ __ ] ride on a wave
that's already there
and when the wave is long gone they
don't understand why they can't ride
that wave anymore
that wave has gone out the tides changed
and everything [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that you think is cool now the
young people who go
and spend money on [ __ ] that's just lame
yeah from their point yeah things are
only cool for us
right but yeah so
even though like i said inferno it's um
it's probably it's one of my favorite
dario argento movies but i mean it's not
a patch on
suspiria obviously but most of his
movies are not
um but it really does have
you know there's a couple things that
could have been better in it like i i
didn't like
um the uh the costuming at the end
like where she comes out of the mirror
and like an issue that you know she's
deaf and everything
because the costuming looked look kind
of cheap um you know the skeleton
grim reaper kind of thing i wish they
had done like a little bit of better job
on
makeup on that um and like i said i
didn't like the keith emerson score as
much as the goblin score although some
of it was like really good i liked the
piano bits and like that operatic thing
at the end
um but but other than that i mean if you
really like suspiria i think you should
really see this because it's kind of
like it's sister film
and it kind of has a lot of you know
similarities it even had like homages
like a couple of the shots like with you
know
uh with uh the woman like sarah like in
the back of the
um cab like with the lighting and the
rain and everything like that just like
the beginning of suspiria and stuff
like i said this was mario baba's uh
last film he did some of the special
effects for it uh his son lombardo baba
also worked on this as well
and another guy that worked on this was
william lustig who later went on to make
maniac he was like he was kind of like
the um
the go-to because he's a new york guy
and uh when he and he was a big fan of
dario argento so when he heard that
dario argento was coming to film for a
week in central park
you know he kind of got in with it and
like kind of got them all and in fact he
asked um he asked um
daria nickelode who is in this movie and
like i said was dario argento's wife at
the time
um he asked her to be in maniac like he
sent her the script and everything
but she hated it so she wouldn't be in
it but like but him
like uh william lustig like getting
together with dario argento and like
letting dario read the script and
the kind of the connections they made
like actually let him make maniac later
on
so he was like super jazz like to meet
dario argento and got to be on the set
and everything like the week that they
were filming in new york
also i have to say one of the one of my
favorite scenes in this [ __ ]
is when [ __ ] kazanian goes to central
park
and he's there's all these cats like
hanging around his shop and i guess the
cats are like representative of like the
witch because it seems like they're
always kind of around and they're always
like attacking people and [ __ ]
so and he's like always bitching about
these cats and then he starts beating up
on the cats which
is very upsetting and he puts them all
in a bag and he's gonna go to [ __ ]
central park and he likes tries to drown
him
and then his crippled ass like falls in
the water and he can't get out
and he's like crying for help and i'm
just kind of like [ __ ] you dude you just
killed all this cat
then all these [ __ ] rats come
swimming and like start eating them and
[ __ ] and then like this guy comes
running over from a hot dog cart and you
think he's gonna save him
and then he just goes chunk and he just
like chops his [ __ ] head he's like
here you go rats eat him up
and i was like yeah that's what you get
don't [ __ ] with cats but yeah so this
one is not like i said it's not quite as
over the top not quite as operatic not
quite as violent
uh it does have a couple scenes like the
whole like window guillotine
type thing and you know there's a couple
stabbings and stuff it's not
you know it doesn't have anything of
like the level of barbed wire rooms or
like the
the open the knife in the open beating
heart type of thing
like they had in suspiria but uh it's
it's definitely definitely worth
watching i think it's one of his better
movies
and it's gorgeous to look at pretty cool
score
um pretty cool like atmosphere like kind
of a creepy
kind of [ __ ] going on and like i said
some of the scenes like the underwater
ballroom and all that stuff are like
amazing like really dreamlike and [ __ ]
like that so
um it's on shutter at the moment and uh
it's probably streaming other places too
um i think suspiria might be on 2b for
free but i don't know if inferno is
but inferno is definitely on shutter so
definitely check it out